how's it going Hans I'm good are you
good yeah that's fun are you good good
we're good it's a good volume nice yeah
just don't get any louder than that okay
if you get louder then just get away
from the mic or just start yelling
internally yep
let's go
what's like the scariest thing that you
think about
[Music]
um
my mom dying and [ __ ]
why your mom family dying oh your family
dying like family members I don't even
hang out with my family so I don't
really care oh good what's the scary
thing you think about man
getting canceled and yeah everyone's
saying you're stupid and they hate you
and then they throw things and like yeah
but that's all to um that's cool with me
that's life
yeah so you that's you don't care about
that no I just well I don't care about
my family dying okay well yeah nobody
yeah
my mom house still helps me out so yeah
I don't trust my siblings so you're
close to your mom close my mom yeah and
you've formed a symbiotic bond with her
yeah I have a kind of a separation
anxiety a break on it very hard
so how often do you call her now that
you're out of town I haven't
honestly while I'm out of town yeah it's
great I don't really call it that much
am I call it
tonight or tomorrow yeah keep rewinding
more
yeah it's just out of this I don't yeah
this is
you just say like I'm fine here you know
yeah there's so many distractions so
many distractions here I'm working I'm
working here to kill Tony what's that
yeah comedy comedy what are you working
on
um besides that any uh any distractions
that are like sexual
I met somebody yesterday no I met
somebody a couple
days ago yeah and I hooked up yesterday
with her nice I got a blow job it was
great
[Laughter]
yeah I haven't had a [ __ ] in a while
welcome to awesome baby without a
[ __ ] condoms why would you wear a
condom because
I usually go to like escorts and stuff
and they make you wear a [ __ ] condom
God so if you're gonna be a [ __ ] be a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I just
pan
hit me up and says
she wanted to hang out I
remember her
on Thursday I think
was her uh body a distraction
shoot nice she's good yes
it's like yeah I mean yeah and
she's a redheads I like redheads and
yeah it was good it was fun and I'm
probably seeing her again this week
that's cool you should uh yeah that's
awesome man
um yeah sexual distractions are really
distracting to me so I don't know how
you handle it are you like trying to see
her every day while you're here or are
you trying to play cool that text much
technology
talk to her just hey good morning yeah
good morning your breath doesn't stink
you know it was like
it's a good distraction I have yeah and
it's a good like companion whatever yeah
yeah but doesn't it distract from the
real work of just writing I just
separated like I know how to separate I
yeah I'm not really
you used to be a more obsession with me
the like analogous
I could decompartment mentalize it yeah
that's the comedy part yeah man but what
if you combine it
what if you combine sex and comedy and
while you're getting a [ __ ] you're
just roasting this [ __ ]
it's like yeah
I'll do that next time anyways what do
you have to ask me
what's your comedy writing process
uh I just lay down in my bed and write
about how we can improve our society and
then I try to take some of that into the
jokes and try to work in my subtle
propaganda no
so saying the r word is improving
Society yeah okay when did I say the r
word
that joke tonight
I don't know I have a bunch of [ __ ]
jokes but yeah I think uh that's
improving Society to be like hey don't
focus on this don't worry about the
words
about the economics economically give us
the money don't worry
yeah you're the best sports right that
give blow jobs without condoms yeah no
yeah um
how you licking your Fame man my fame oh
it's great I love it you know it's good
it's a lot of pressure you know with
with a lot of positivity comes like the
fear of it going away yeah and more
attention and more criticism so I feel
like I'm pretty balanced out please
don't uh feel the need to like you know
put me down more no because I'm already
around I'm already down no love man I'm
reload just the natural pressure of all
you can knock down
get up again yeah well some people are
like oh you're you're doing well so I
can just like [ __ ] all over you I have
that problem
a problem I had this I have this
[Music]
Toronto yeah and like
a lot of people love to
bring it up and it's like rabbit oh
yeah
you killed Tony famous there's a
celebrity it is I'm like yeah I'm just
human right now you know yeah even when
they're saying it in a positive way you
can hear the vitriol and the right
and the jealousies by some other Comics
yeah so it's like brought us funny yeah
so either I have to take this in and be
sad or I can just be like oh you're
pathetic you're a hater so it's like
you're making me either like hate myself
or hate you so don't put me in that
position no act like you've been there
before [ __ ] right I had I mean fight
with people I have to yeah
now I leave situations if that happens I
just leave yeah that's good yeah there's
no reason to entangle yourself with a
bunch of weak little right normal people
no
and like this it's yeah Life's too short
man like
you have to be happy for other people
man you got to be happy for other people
and it's the thing is it's a muscle yeah
and also
um
[Music]
walk what other people have right you
want what other people have like I want
I saw you
post things
on your
private jet and stuff your work
experience yeah
and like I I could be jealous of it
or
I can say hey
I'm happy for you because I want what
you have
yeah you got to turn into a positive
because if you turn into negative it's
going to be toxic and you're gonna
[ __ ] think about it all day just
attack yourself yeah man but I think
um you don't have to like necessarily
go out of your way to like look at what
other people are doing and then you know
it's better if you're just like hey I'm
living a good life I'm having a good
time so let me just keep doing that and
not to worry too much about other people
it's also good to have
goals too right and like separate like
goals from like
jealousy you know yeah like
write it down and just like
yeah so for that yeah I mean I am
obviously jealous of people that are
living like awesome lives and I don't
like try to like
change it too much I'm just like hey I
just you know wish that this was
happening for me and you have it and
like I hope you know that I'm jealous of
you but in a good way and I don't know I
don't really feel the need to always
make it like into something positive
cozy it's not a good
emotion to have
I'm like you know like I don't know like
but if it crops up I don't like try to
be like oh I should change it no just
think of a moment or just
I think the poison is in the dose if
they have a lot of jealousy then that's
bad but if you're like oh I like that
what he has anyways back to my life but
if it becomes a distraction from your
life then it's bad but you can have it
you just have to let it pass through you
I think there is a difference of
being jealous of somebody and kind of
[Music]
wanting what they have I think they're
too different yeah things because like
like that's my goal that's my goal
there's a guy at the Finish Line right I
want to be there right
work yeah you get what
like
so what do you think the process is for
you
like what are you gonna do to get to
that next level
writing and uh
I have to
take the opportunities I'm
given yeah
golden ticket winners that actually come
here like a lot of golden ticket winners
are like oh I don't want to go there
right it's like dude you got this
opportunity and you're just wasting it
because you're such an artist right such
a [ __ ] people give me [ __ ]
[ __ ] with that
people
how can we come for a long time because
I want to put myself up there I need to
put energy out there yeah you're you're
right there
you know you're like you're not like oh
life is just whatever and I'm just gonna
get through it you're like oh [ __ ] we're
here we're excited about life exactly a
lot of people are like I don't want to
make a big wave I don't want to [ __ ]
make them impact it's like [ __ ] and
that's the game you're in the comedy
show business do those people who say
that so
miserable miserable yeah like those
people say oh I don't want to make a
splash I don't want to yeah
they're not happy
people you know yeah because they're
always muting themselves and they're
always like oh I'm better than what I'm
being shown right on TV as I'm just
gonna take this little idea of myself
and just masturbate to it
instead of being like hey put it out
there and use society and the audience
to make yourself better like a
scratching post they're there to
be a little guide marker and then your
real audience is posterity and the
internet and the future and people 500
years from now watching me jerk off on a
webcam
and that's the art you do webcams yeah
this is a technically a camera
not really okay no
what do you think of artificial
intelligence I think it's the future and
I think we should try to mimic our
logical mind as close to it as possible
right and sort of like not fight and try
to be animals because it feels good but
also have like a decent uh piping system
like get AI to be like hey this is the
best way to make a pipe okay let's do
that then instead of being like no I
gotta use my instincts and my animal
strength to make this pipe right
AI kind of scares me
no no I just I have a robot gave me
[ __ ] nightmares
robots no the movie I Robot yeah well
that's a very Western thing like that's
a cultural thing because like in Japan
they love robots right robots are their
friends but in America they're like oh
we gotta fight the [ __ ] thing that's
where is our slave right now because I
think of slavery yeah they're like
they're used to their farm equipment
taking [ __ ] from but
but yeah I mean I think like we have a
system that maybe wouldn't be the best
incompatible with AI because we have a
system that's like you know the
strongest can win and whoever's
strongest wins and it's like oh well the
AI is going to be stronger than us right
well why don't we have a system that
isn't based on strength and power and
knowledge and taking over right but then
we'd have to change everything about us
so we're like well AI is going to beat
us because we're all trying to beat each
other so we're just gonna have to get
used to being a servant to AI or maybe
we could get rid of this master servant
Dynamic altogether
um and have you know symbiotic
relationships where we all help each
other
but uh that's that's why I think people
are afraid of right I think yeah helping
each other
we all have
all
happening
we all have to just yeah support it for
each other especially in the you can
come in the community and just
everything and financially fun yeah give
me your money [ __ ] you know I didn't
yeah
Cameo no
I don't like Cameo do you do you like uh
doodoo Cameo I do Cameo William does
Cameo he loves it yeah it's fun yeah
it's like a little sketch you got to do
for each person yeah you just get the
like
and this people
include you in their experiences so
that's cool you get to be a part of
someone's life yeah you know you got to
just yeah what do you normally say if
you have to say whatever they do an
example like
do you want me to do an example Cameo
right now sure hey what's up yeah hey
what's up Brad welcome to your 34th
birthday I hope you don't rape as many
chicks this year
um also the Jews are not that bad please
stop posting anti-semitic messages on
your Twitter and also Brad how about
this time you shower this year huh you
fat [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] okay peace
forty dollars thanks
people ask me this
to say all sort of things I broke up
with somebody for somebody
um
yeah
uh yeah I just I broke up with somebody
I broke off I told somebody hey somebody
asked me to break up with their ex so I
broke up with them I don't know if
that's safe I don't know I do what they
thought [ __ ] Jared Nathan this
[ __ ] that make us lockers but no
um no I just fun I'm just like
yeah just it's all from Kill Tony man
all the cameos there's like everything
like oh everything just
so they're not afraid to say [ __ ] and
they're more like down for the clown you
know down from the ground down not down
from the syndrome you know down for the
broken clown
broken broken yeah we're all broken do
you think that uh you have less
inhibitions that make you more free and
more intellectually flexible than a lot
of these people that are just like hi
I'm Bob oh I must be a decent human
today like you're just existing you're
in the moment and all these other people
they're in their heads they're got
khakis on they're riding up into a gooch
they can't no man I do therapies though
oh so you get a lot of [ __ ] figured out
I just I'm trying to figure it out like
I'm getting that's a process yeah like
I'm getting over trauma [ __ ] so
or normal I know
here's the thing I know
what society's
sees me as well like I know
what the ignorant Society sees me as
yeah and I know what I am and that's not
what they see me as and that little and
if that little like
uh thing that doesn't match you get to
play with that that little area yeah and
be like oh you thought I was like this
let me just say this because that would
be funny right and you have a superpower
yeah man company of the superpower yeah
or it can be just like words like
produce emotions and it's like a magic
spell right and I realized how insecure
normal people are
how insecure are they just
extremely and like I have a problem that
I liked if I see somebody's weakness
attack I attack I'm working on it well I
think that's the evolutionary thing
because if you're hanging out with a
dude and you're hunting and you're
surviving with them and they have a
weakness and you don't address it they
might be like oh that bear really
thought I was fat and ugly I'm so mad
I'm gonna kill Hans in asleep so you
gotta like address that [ __ ] before it
boils over in the most industry people's
surprise you
because like I see people
who are like good looking and they have
a car yeah yes he's talking about me
sure
I don't yeah you think I'm ugly now
that's my insecurity no man I'm just I'm
just
I'm surprised how insecure normal people
are yeah and then then
that's just what the [ __ ] normal
then you're like oh [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
up right
so now I don't have to be like
self-conscious right and like are they
are normal people
the real people with special needs are
not special needs the real normal people
They got normal needs
yeah I just think that like yeah you
just
surprise me
how like how many people
are weakening yeah even though
I know somebody in
Toronto
who's a personal trainer who's [ __ ]
jacked up like a second yeah yeah
picturing it now like
make Indian guy like okay
I'll picture it yeah he was white in my
head oh yeah a picture in India and like
I could destroy him in two seconds
like I can destroy him mentally mentally
like a [ __ ] within the head in two
seconds yeah that's a cool thing to do
yeah but
I know whatever it's not cool I don't
I'm not happy about it but it just
sometimes it comes out like I'm in like
a joking mood yeah especially like in
the comedy club I feel really sad yeah
and I'm like I'm like grow up like I'm
like grow up you [ __ ] sexy ass Indian
you know
[ __ ] imagine
no man yeah it just drives an Uber yeah
no I think it's great that uh you know
we have uh uh the social ability because
we're always out we're always talking to
people yeah
um I think like talking to people is
such a beautiful intimate gift yeah and
sometimes people are not ready for it
and uh you know it's it's we're all
strangers and we all have to like
Pretend We're not to some degree but
yeah I think without connecting and
talking to people is like something
that's like really powerful and that we
should be like using it for good enough
communication itself is a powerful tool
yeah the the most some people take for
granted so what is it about this Indian
guy that you like to make fun of no I
just
just this conversation like
he was his weakness was his insecurities
I'm like um
he came up to the library
uh
aggressively right and I'm like
whoa whoa
like some people walk up
their hands like this yeah and I'm just
trying to dab you up
Yeah but I
he was more of like a location like
dude
directly like punch me in the face yeah
he did it aggressively yeah
and like I was like Hey like
you wanna fight right I would like
jokeally smiling yeah oh I'm sorry man
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I feel bad now and he kept
telling me Oh I feel bad I'm like
well don't feel bad
yeah I brought it back I bring the thing
is people don't like
I mean much energy
yeah I
I'm like I'm much energy you're like oh
you came at me aggressively let me right
jokingly now pretend like you wanted a
fight let's do a bit right but then if
you say sorry sorry I'm so sorry that
kind of killed that's like no budding
right you got a yes and right right
exactly some people will be like oh yeah
I want to fight I don't want to beat
your little butthole in with my penis oh
no I revealed too much yeah like they
have no chill like when they are in
fight mode they can't joke about it
right because it's just so serious to
them so they're not intellectually free
they're like fighting is this and when
I'm in the fight mode no one can defeat
me
like well I'm in a comedy zone I'm in a
comedy zone you know what I mean yeah
like yes and just go with things
yeah it's a fun game it's a fun game of
exercise right do you want to do it
right now
yes give me your money
yes I'll give you your money and not
only that I'll give you my butthole and
my virginity would you like to [ __ ] me
let's go where
yeah
let's [ __ ] you yeah please would you be
[ __ ] have you been do you do anything
I I Peg women with mine
you I've never had a chick Peg Me Oh
Good
do they have to wear a condom in Canada
for the escorts when they Peg you
or can I just get a new dildo
depends
depends is what you're going to be
wearing after you get pegged
so yeah
so what's with the escort situation in
Canada
what do you mean what are they why
government cheese like government [ __ ]
are like sort of like powdered milk
they're like I have used like I have
used government cheese cheese yeah
that's course that's what you asked no
um
Quebec
like it's a dude sometimes yeah I mean
it's a government yeah they're all woke
there it used to be I identify as a
woman
and you have to like get pegged by a
dude it's scary
um no man I
yeah I don't
I haven't
used them as um
watch that I did
before before kill Tony like in my 20s
and stuff I haven't really I used them
you were going on a craze in your 20s
yeah a lot and then escorting your dick
into vaginas
um shots particles and stuff like that
soft what I saw you
parlors so hj's do you have to wear a
condom for an HJ no thank God no hello
yeah but I once got an HJ at a massage
parlor nice it was some woman's
apartment
I was just going into some apartment
complex I've been there getting jerked
off and I didn't know this is my first
time getting a massage parlor jerk yeah
so I just held it in as long as possible
because I wanted more money more bang
for my buck and more Strokes for a
dollar right and then I didn't tell them
I was coming yeah I was just like
and then they were like oh my God yeah
oh whoa you didn't tell us oh so much
semen yeah and then I try to take a
shower and this woman just kept poking
her head and it's like [ __ ] I'm taking
a shower like I know you saw my [ __ ]
already yeah
I want some privacy yeah
I've been I've been like almost raw
before
just like in the shower they go through
your
pants that I had to experience one time
[Music]
it's a CD industry but that is it legal
in Canada
you have to get a license
loopholes for your poop holes like
[Music]
um
write it one time your butthole was
rated
not my butthole
after the session yeah yeah I just ended
the session and then
and it's up and it's up finish up it's a
red it's a really nice Canadian right
right oh sorry there why don't you right
why don't you come and then we'll come
right back and arrest you right that's
cool finish up and then I came out and
then what kind of policeman yeah it
starts to raid by telling you to finish
your dirty business
yeah they weren't very concerned
with myself they're more focusing on
their establishment they just won't want
to do yeah God yeah they don't want you
to
come on them
but like I got it loaded and ready to
fire watch out Congress
yep did you come on a policeman
did you come near a policeman no okay
like yeah
well
um yeah one time I went to uh prasi uh
prostitution
man
yo
put a Connie on you're going to [ __ ] a
prosie
um yeah and she has to see my ID
I was like [ __ ]
I'm gonna get my ID but I'm not gonna be
happy about it yeah but I was like I was
like 24. oh God like if a if a prozy
asked for my ID I'd be like [ __ ] let me
see your ID yeah what the [ __ ] are we
doing IDs now I don't want the
government to know I was here yeah I had
a
I'm his appointment and she wouldn't see
me because I had because I look like I
was
I had the same sort of experience
because you look like you work in Tech
yes I would say [ __ ] but yeah same
thing no you're on I don't know yeah
just tell them that you're you work for
a SpaceX right you're like [ __ ]
you think I'm [ __ ] I think you're a
[ __ ]
dumb yeah like you should you should
challenge them to a math off start doing
multiplication let's go
so what's like your uh
uh favorite best subject in school
lunch no um
oh yeah
I enjoyed like social studies and
current
you like that politics yeah like they're
a political guy I like yeah I liked uh
learning about things from other
countries like not so much history but
exactly M M's
Pro or against sexy M MS
the green ones the green ones the brown
they're all sexy I'm okay with them okay
why what's wrong with
well it's wrong with the old road
running the elements I like that's the
old ones they're boring they're not
they're platonic they don't have the
curves that we're looking for in 2023 we
want everything black cells
voluptuous voluptuous cells I think
they're trying to go for a more feminism
angle they're like look we support women
we've got women M M's
but
well
women don't support wmea so
yeah when women support
this female M M's
I don't know
whatever your thoughts not really a good
market for M M's I don't think women are
really into thoughts what I don't think
women are really into M M's
are you the
it's real folks um are you the
peanut M M's
[Music]
I don't like either they're like either
no no that's white people stuff
what are you into Snickers hockey sticks
Pokey sticks
Pocky sticks yeah no I like that I grew
up with that I like the chocolate part
but then you get to the handle part and
it's like what's the point of this the
cracker yeah it tastes awful yeah
um but yeah I just like the chocolate
powder I throw the handle part away okay
um yeah what do you think about but Joe
Biden's classified documents that were
found all over his property why are you
laughing this is National Security
what you're just so sick of it I'm sick
of Joe Biden but yeah what has he done
he's just he's barely there you could
it's hard to get sick of him he just
sound bites him with him
lose his mind
and
proclaiming his daughter on it you know
well the fact is the country isn't going
to [ __ ] so we don't even need a
president if Joe Biden can be president
that job is useless
why do we even have him and the thing
about the president
or
just uh spokesperson so to speak right
yeah
right right
their people actually
tell him what to say and
speech writers you know there are people
in the air all the time yeah there's
people that's gelling his hair and you
know putting extra wrinkles on his face
yeah
sniff a young girl's hair
that's all it was Speech writer some
some guy and yeah and things funny about
go
bunnies
he settled a lot of things
enough
the path is opposite to what he's saying
now so yeah like I love black people
back in the day he was like take put
them on another bus they smell you went
there yeah
right and then he was like marijuana
five years in jail minimum now he's like
uh no comment right it's like oops you
were wrong about that and you're pretty
much just a republican wait
do you think like uh gay marriage is
like something that he was against
probably I know he's so old yeah that's
probably nothing wrong with that
it was probably against the Taft Carter
Act
and the tariffs on the the T from
Britain yeah so old
tea party tea party so what did you
think about the Canadian Truckers
I'm all right with
I'm okay with people standing up for
their freedom I think freedom is a
important and I think
a lot of people
or
a lot of people get sucked in
in the government and
believing to have you put the best
interests and heart but we really don't
so who does the government have the best
interests of them
whoever who's them the government
[Music]
um
yeah for the truckers
they blew everything out of a person I
don't think
they took money out of their
bank accounts and everything yeah they
got scared they froze GoFundMe it's all
control right yeah they froze in the
trucks or out in Canada and then for us
are banking got their bank accounts
match their fingers right not to the
temperature outside
nobody in Canada
we didn't
it's only
legal sort of government can make
money off it yeah like it's not it's
it's governed and it's controlled and it
is who controls the government
I don't know who do you think
money interests yeah Rich corporations
yeah
everything around me but cash money you
know right
everything yeah I think it's horrible
and that we should have a government
that's really run by the people and the
people need to make rich people afraid
we're gonna be like hey watch out if you
don't do what we want right we're gonna
go all out France on you put on yellow
vests and start throwing flares around
and right you know
being mean to policemen
yes Sakura blood right you smell like a
smellier frog than I am
are you for the fun in the police or uh
I think in some American cities the
police get a large share of the budget
and that should be not the police's job
because anything there's a problem with
we're like just send the police there
like that should be like you know taking
care of people Social Services yeah yeah
so I believe in that but I think like
police are very necessary I think the
police in America have like a horrible
culture yeah that needs to be fixed but
I I mean policemen take up so much of
the budget in most cities and it's just
like just throw money at the problem
and it's sort of like welfare for Irish
people
okay
what do you think potatoes
um
yeah I I think that the mental health
aspects could be taken care of yeah
um more and just look at them as
criminals yeah because
yeah it's just but also
there's a
place for Law and Order
good sometimes cops
don't
they can't always do what do you think
they can
yeah well like
if you can't
robbed by someone and they can't really
help you yeah they would tell you they
can't help you I can't legally chase
them right without a permit from the
magistrate yeah
especially like our situations where I
got robbed
in the
past stuff I knew I knew exactly
heard that people
were worse off and they wouldn't do
anything about it yeah that's happening
in Austin right now the police are on a
working strike they won't solve anything
are they on the Market Street yeah okay
they're just grumpy because they can't
kill black people anymore
but uh yeah it turns out we don't really
you know need them that much because
everything is sort of working out fine
like we are nicer to each other than I
think people realize and if we have
enough like social like safety nets and
like you know people weren't suffering
imagine how much nicer we'd be we're
already so nice already
yeah but I think
suffering is
can be good like
you can take you
you have to feel
pain to appreciate
pleasure you know yeah but not much pain
everybody has different holes man
everybody has different thresholds but
it's different is that like why they're
doing it they're like putting us through
pain relief corporations so that's hard
for us in order to save money
I think corporations are very
greedy yeah corporations don't really
think about us They think about yeah
they're a paycheck they're not really
think about it they're like a creature
they're not really human right they're
just like
rep simply you know the reptilians yeah
it's a very like calculating way to
think right we feel it we feel The
Reptilian nature crushing down on us
right
um anyways so yeah I think like
um
uh yeah they're so greedy that they're
just taking everything and leaving us
nothing and then we're like suffering
right but yeah I mean I think people are
the future
like we gotta just trust ourselves like
if people all it takes for someone to be
bad is like having health care and food
and rent then we're [ __ ] because
that's all it takes for humans to just
be lazy and die like we might as well
get there like to have like suffering be
part of the economy so that we can limit
human suffering seems a little
um circular
yeah yeah to like
yeah I don't know
also
we just can't play victims right A lot
of people want to play victims to their
things yeah it feels good
that way you don't have to do anything
yeah but
you won't
go higher if you're going to bring
yourself well I don't know I'm I'm
working on that deter right what do you
think about violent revolutions
you need to protect yourself when the
time comes you know yeah do you have a
gun no you can't have a gun in Canada
right and you can with the yeah you make
it really hard they make it real they
make it really hard-hearted
yeah it makes you real it's Justin
Trudeau you know make it real [ __ ] to
get a gun you can say that you said that
yeah you said it too last week
[Music]
but I said [ __ ] is that is that okay
it's it's it's
well
I have to step
back yeah and like choose when the
ticket your battle personal choose my
battles yeah sometimes it's harder than
in others it's about the intent behind
their eyes right they're Beaty little
eyes
you're sure otherwise you can't see my
intent no you can't see you I can't see
your eyes but I could be saying it
hatefully you know you'd have no idea
because of how [ __ ] my little cedar or
eyebrows your recorders yeah so your
forehead eyebrows if my eyebrows are
high what does that mean
you say [ __ ] I don't even say that I
say mentally [ __ ]
that's worse mentally Down syndrome
um yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] because it looks like you're
trying to make it sound like official
yeah I don't know
the
word itself
if you look it up
in the dictionary yeah it just means
slow and
yeah I'm a little slow and delayed the
whole world is
people just
put the negative
thing out there yeah because they have
negative connotation if we just change
the word all the time we're never going
to address the actual root cause of the
intent and being nice to everyone and
they just want to be like hey the new
word is and in five years that's gonna
be a slur now too right so why don't we
just stop chasing the goose and just
like love [ __ ] people love everybody
love them without a condom on everybody
what about everybody what about Hitler
except him
um
I love Hitler
is your name Kanye
I don't love what he did
I hate we love everybody yeah I love you
know he's probably chill gotta hang out
with
he's a he's a doer he accomplishes his
goals a lot of people sit around don't
do anything
foreign
I can't
I just don't
yeah just I I lost family like my family
will watch family members in the
Holocaust and stuff like that why they
were they the Jewish the guard Tower oh
okay my family oh you're a Jew yeah oh
my God so that's why you're so funny
yeah I'm Jewish from Jewish I'm [ __ ]
so I mean that's what I'm actually funny
no um but no um they're like a normal
white person right
yeah this is fun yeah no yeah I am yeah
I'm 44 percent Jewish
yeah and then I'm Irish okay
um
yeah I remember yeah I'm Irish and
Scottish so you're Northern Jewish well
oh my
biological father's side I'm uh
Russian and Russian Jewish and my
biological mom's side of Irish Scottish
some French nice yeah so a Russian Jew
meets a Scottish French yeah
and she's like how much for the baguette
you know yeah
you know
I want it no um
are you uh
do you ever make racial jokes
oh
uh racial yeah I touched on I have I
don't do it but
what's your least favorite rice
people no oh no sir I don't wanna
honestly I don't really go there I make
like I have a
the first joke I did on show Tony my
first parents I have a joke this is
Rarities between black people and people
with special needs nice that's kind of
where I go yeah I put myself with a
punchline of a joke yeah like we both
shout at movie theaters it gets real you
know
um
right
yeah it's like a little dinosaurs
or like you know
yeah
they make trees now little chicken
fingers yeah you guys both love wearing
oversized clothes
hey
yeah anyways anyways yeah yeah no but I
I love
everybody get old I don't also I don't
wanna like
I don't really
I don't try to be offensive yeah
sometimes sometimes it just comes with
being funny like sometimes you know what
I mean yeah sometimes it's
like sometimes
you can easily go like
a little too far just because that's
where the fun is yeah
but like
you don't have intent of that yeah I
don't intend
to
it's no anger
yeah behind it you know it's just a
funny yeah it's just like when you start
noticing differences between races you
gotta you might be like well that one is
better let me do more of that because
you just gotta can't you can't like be
like oh this one's better you're just
gonna be like oh it's different right
just focus on it but different
yeah and definitely I hate Asians I hate
more Asians than I do any other race
because I just meet more shitty Asians
right
cousins though huh you all try to tell
you they're
related no fortunately Asians aren't
black like that
yo
this is my impression of a black person
pretending to be a cousin
I give up
I'm sorry I tried yeah I shouldn't have
tried
[Music]
back in the day
but back in the day I was back in the
day I was blocking the gay oh oh oh here
we go
we just start rapping let's go they say
this is Hans Kim love you hansy yeah
holy crap great guess they said this is
gold they said is it live stream yeah
we're live stream right now yeah
anything you want to say controversial
where is the live stream youtube.com
okay
it'll be up after the live stream too
I'll send you the link let's do it oh
my message to all the women out there
you guys are not having enough sex we
could be like gay people but we're stuck
here being like [ __ ] puritanical
let's go Florence Nightingale in the
1700s get with it yeah let's [ __ ] check
me out to Instagram
share Nathan comedy baby
check me out on
where should I say wherever you are man
check me out right or did it hello check
me on a j grinder J grinder yeah no oh
yeah okay dates all right
that's what they call this print the
showers and out shirts of the J grinder
yo you want to smoke some of this
Ashkenazi Kush
smoking up
this old like stupid joke
probably yeah no I don't want to say it
it's okay
how do you fit six million Jews in a
Volkswagen
oh bro you asked them nicely boom
to get in good rankings
there's looking there's so many yeah so
many Nazi companies out there man yeah
Volkswagen
they were like let's give all the money
to our corporations in big business
right
let's not give it to the workers yeah so
yeah I mean Volkswagen Hugo Boss
Coca-Cola I think cocoa had had things
to do with it oh my God I don't think
it's invented but I think they had uh
they had some they had some little hands
in it George Bush's grandfather helped
launder money
sure damn you know George Bush's
grandfather's name he's from Maine
Prescott Bush friend of the Nazis
um [ __ ] Henry Ford was really down with
the Nazis like I love what you're doing
the Jews are a problem
and I agree with you
yeah and then the Jews were in Hollywood
um
yeah they're annoying
what's the most annoying thing a Jew's
ever done to you
wait you're Jewish I'm Jewish
um
I've been ripped off but it's all good
oh classic classic like that's so
stereotypic try to tell me faker
bracelets fake watches in high school oh
that's hilarious they're like little
gremlins they're like little little like
goblins from a movie they're like I
ain't got some gold for you all right
just kidding what are the common thing
boycott Prescott
volcano Vape made in Germany just saying
um never knew that but
um who they know a thing or two about
heating things up and creating smoke out
of them light it up light it up it was a
little gas chamber for the week
that's pretty much the
you smoke weed yeah yeah yeah what do
you prefer nickel sativa hybrid I never
know what's your favorite string I don't
have a favorite strain I just smoke it
and feel different and I'm like well I
feel different okay I've never noticed
the difference between indica and sativa
oh God
what are you I like sativa more of like
a head or a concert type yeah and then
Indica just couch lock yeah just ah
relax
sometimes like
panic I don't know I don't know oh
that's the opposite I'm not really just
in the car just
in the gaming anxiety yeah for other
people
get some anxiety wow but I prefer I
prefer like
sativa
nice so uh does that help your
depression and your anxiety are you do
you think you're self-medicating like an
antidepressant
if I step it that's not
tombs and acid are for the
self-mindicating the depression yeah
we
like like
we're just like
regulates me you know
regulate just regularly an Elevate baby
hell yeah I love it you knew the rhyme
um yeah I love it I think weed it's like
uh you know like some people take Prozac
I take weed yeah just makes me happier
you know I think it's good for me to
smoke weed
um and I think it's uh weird to like not
smoke weed right but I've been thinking
like
um moderation like you know if you if
all you do all day it hit them
yeah without doing other things
it's not that might not be a good thing
right if you just take a puff or
something go to the gym or take a pop
yeah go you're gonna become productive
you got to be productive you know yeah
you can't yeah but if your life is
shitty you have no prospects
and just smoke weed and just [ __ ] be
a little cocoon until you've turned into
a butterfly and then you [ __ ] you
know plus I am wait what's um yes wheat
is a nice little
thing sometimes
what do you think about
Austin Texas comedy
he was
go for it man people just go for it yeah
there's no second guess there's no
second guess the only thing is funny
yeah they're not afraid of what the
audience thinks yeah which in
Toronto
tomorrow that can
be a problem that's why I stand up
comedy is an American founded art form
because you can't care too much about
Society also or you can't care too much
about
I mean you got to care about Society but
you can't you can't care about their
sensibilities no or like their weird
little quirks you gotta care about their
but you don't care what's funny yeah and
what's funny can't be unclear they're a
little weird you know right and what's
funny is uncomfortable sometimes yeah
and like here
comes in Canada can uh
can be more sense In Their audience yeah
with guardians like they're calling to
tell me I can't say this I can't say
that yeah then I say the audience loves
it yeah there's stuff with their own
heads about it they don't want to
explore that part of themselves because
they're afraid of what they'll find yes
and they're like I said more here Comics
here just go for the funny man yeah
that's what it's weird right yeah I love
it a concept
wait and like it makes you more free of
the comic yeah
you just go for the funny instead of
just like censoring yourself yeah it's
like juggling uh uh you know a juggling
juggling thing right and also doing a
tightrope walk it's like why don't you
just focus on the tightrope walk right
why do you juggle right it's like who
are you express yourself without fear of
social repercussion right I want to know
if you're a Nazi go out there and tell
me now I know you're a Nazi yeah and
also
it's okay to have different opinions man
it's okay to not have the same opinion
as somebody's sitting across me it's
okay that's okay we're doing it right
now it's okay not to have
um you have to like
or be a hundred percent you know yeah
okay because you have different views
yeah getting along doesn't mean having
the same views on things no getting
along means respect it means chilling it
means vibing it means riffing and yes
ending and not being closed off and
creating dead ends right anyways what do
you think about abortion
I'm pro-life hell yeah oh no but I my
own situation like and also
um
what they don't talk about most people
don't talk about is like
a lot of people with Down Syndrome are
reported right and that's where I come
from that's a situation where I
I'm not personal normally I just
yeah I just feel
some connection to it yeah you think
like people just judging ultrasounds is
probably not the best way to right I
know of situations
where somebody I used to
work with yeah when she was pregnant
with her
the [ __ ]
and
um
they told her that she her daughter who
would have Down syndrome and her
daughter
I don't have Down syndrome yeah so it's
not accurate yeah so
it can't be
the judge jury and execution no you
can't without the proper info right and
like
yeah did nothing wrong with having a
child with
disabilities yeah it's not them to have
a problem maybe it's you yeah I don't
know I'm just it's different with a look
at it
yeah
um I
yeah I'm I'm
so what do you think about like
abortions in space
any of the right number no yeah
of course if you're in a situation and
like
you
a female he's like
raped in something I understand that
situation in space in space or in Mars
and Uranus oh [ __ ] and my anus Uranus
maintenance yes no I understand like
I just I
yeah it's my own situation
yeah it's like yeah no in space I think
we should have more compassion I don't
think we have a very compassionate
society and if you let women just murder
babies then they're probably not gonna
do it right and like
yeah and like
you could also accountability right
like if you have sex then you should
have a baby
it's whatever it is yeah just
well I love abortion because it makes
women more [ __ ] like if you can just
kill babies and you're like yeah back
again I'll [ __ ] you right just kill it
later so I love that personally for me
um and I also think like maybe like
rape you should be able to kill rapist
babies
yeah
um but yeah I think in general like
we're not really dying for more people
but if if everyone is on board with uh
you know
birth control I think we could get rid
of a lot of playing condoms yeah condoms
I don't know I hate condoms yeah
I mean I like condoms because it saves
you
it's just like oh I'm probably gonna
have sex if I smell a condom but it's
like sexist sex is coming yeah your
senses oh you know yeah
yay condoms yeah but overall it kind of
makes it hard for me to come
and it also doesn't feel good all the
time it doesn't feel as good but it
feels better than your hand so great
do you have a hard time coming sometimes
I have a hard time coming sometimes
sometimes unless it's with a girl that
I've been with for a while then I come
too quickly because I know how to use
her vaginas sometimes you thank me yeah
but sometimes you come really quick and
then the second time it's like
takes longer you can go you can go I can
go oh I can who's going I can go you're
just leaving no they come in second time
after the first you can come oh I can
yeah refractory period
I just need some more motivation
whatever when I was young I was always
like interested in my penis is feeling
good yeah my pen eye but as I get older
I'm like the penis is just a tool to get
a woman to like me right so if she's
ready to go after the first orgasm I'm
just like hey buddy I need you come on
wake up wake up yeah it's it's a slave I
rule my penis with an iron film I want
to rule you rule yeah
my penis is an obedient little slave to
me like I need you right now buddy I
know you're tired yeah I want to [ __ ]
this girl mentally you know yeah
so it's just a tool for me okay but yeah
I love my penis
I jerk off a little bit too much yeah I
think I need to stop watching porn
because like the way that I look at
women now it's like yeah it can be yeah
I'm just used to watching I'm not used
to like yeah because like if you look at
a woman in a weird way it it ruins any
conversation that you might have with
her right and that is pointless if
you're just staring at church
uh the joy that you get from that is not
good enough to sacrifice well yeah I
just yeah I'm standing Rings calm you
know who are coming no I just
staring at a woman you can bring you
like yeah you can bring you this calm
you know yeah because that's funny
because it's usually doing the opposite
for the woman right so yeah staring at
her she's panicking I'm getting more
calm Yeah the more panicking a girl is
the calmer I get I get turned on by
Panic yeah
Panic at the Disco at the Disco
yes cool oh yeah yeah
let's pound it out pound pound it like
we're gonna pound some chicks Tonight
Tony yeah so you excited for tonight are
you ready yeah I'm ready and excited
let's go
I'm excited yes oh see you there I'm
gonna abort some babies tonight nice
get them ovaries ready all right we're
gonna shoot some proper Pole
right okay so someone says
what does that open the door to I don't
know what they're talking about
um what do you think about
death
it's there you're scared of it yeah
it's not it can be scary but just enjoy
what's here no yeah I mean I'm gonna be
just in the moment so when I'm about to
die I'm gonna be in the moment and be
like oh so this is what it feels like to
die enjoy enjoy what's happening now
yeah I mean just because you're dead
doesn't mean that everyone else is enjoy
what's now yeah well so much of me is in
other people you know okay yeah we don't
have to talk about death what do you
think about birth
it's
babies are barely well if it's there for
the two guaranteed in life right yeah
and taxes yes
I think very [ __ ] yes is like the baby
we have a short gestation period our
babies come out quicker than they're
ready to they're not because we have big
heads and small vaginas right so we pop
them out quick yeah because we're
bipedal we gotta walk so we have
narrower hips or whatever
um and these babies they're barely human
right if you if you see a newborn it's
like not doing anything so I say it's
okay to kill
a baby until you get to like okay maybe
when it like looks at you in the eye and
like recognizes and then it's okay yeah
then it's not okay to kill it cool
unless you really need to
okay whatever
[Laughter]
no I'm kidding yeah I know
um what do you think about war and the
army
okay without agreed everything's out of
greed agreed everything out of agree
like out of uh yeah it's oil it's oil
yeah one of them oil and it's like
um I don't want to go
it's a man
made sometimes sometimes like albums too
old you know like sometimes
disguise something else this is
distraction from what's up what's
actually going on yeah we're like oh no
our country's falling apart quick let's
attack something yeah and it can have
arterial motives yeah like getting laid
Yeah and it's like
yes saying going for something else and
then
going for something else yeah say going
for
weapons and mass destruction we were
going for like
control and power control oil power yeah
having a base in the Middle East right
which to attack other countries right
it's like one area where we're like oh
you don't want to do what we say you
have pride and you're like standing up
to us well [ __ ] you yeah and no I was
act like soldiers and stuff I respect
them yeah you got to you right they're
helping you they're doing it
for Freedom right yeah that's what the
Louis CK joke is about he's like he
thinks he's helping and that's good
enough he doesn't actually have to be
helping as long as he thinks he's doing
that he's coming from a good place
mentality is key yes yeah
yeah
man
um yeah yeah I mean I I look soldiers I
just think that uh over history since
the Vietnam War
they really haven't been utilized
correctly and to sign yourself up to
that I'm like
well you're just asking for to be abused
no but I mean I think it's a great way
to uh train the human mind I mean that
makes sense for an animal like us is to
be like oh yeah I can survive and take
care of myself and hurt others that are
trying to hurt me right so I think it
does a lot for people right
what do you think about uh just
everything overall
Everything is Everything
about
[Music]
everything is exciting everything can be
exciting when do you uh what what do you
think about this whole trip so far this
Austin trip this is like your fourth
time right my fourth time I had some
good experiences hopefully I'll
have things that I want to happen
hopefully so if anyone is new to Austin
what do you recommend Mondays kill Tony
obviously yeah
karaoke yeah come for karaoke or
Thursday Secret show
go check out some good
barbecue check out some good music Terry
blacks check out the other hour check
out Alice Bullard yeah
that's a good place one of my favorites
um
some good coffee places
thank you check out Tony kill Tony yeah
uh give him a quick up and down like ooh
check him out check them out man check
out yeah check out a library book
yeah check out
I've been
um
like go take a walk your lake is cool
like a river yeah
they call a lake a river lake the
Colorado River yeah yeah
check out the scenery check out Sixth
Street check out uh
okay yeah what do you think about me
you're funny thank you oh
it's not even funny too you're a good
guy man thank you man you're good
as well you brought me here very
it's good I
have good energy I mean like
yeah
it's
in your stories I'm like inspiring man
thank you man yeah story is definitely
inspiring definitely like
what I want your story is definitely
like
what I want and what right because a lot
of comments you want yeah yeah and it's
like oh hey if you just keep writing
jokes for nine years and live in a van
maybe you could also how you talk about
it's like three times a day we'll be
talking about Deport you kind of
living in the van was kind of like a
suffering so to speak right yeah and
then
you're suffering lead
to you like headline now opening over
Rogan successfully yeah being on a
private jet yeah it's amazing that it
worked out I'm still pinching myself
yeah I'm like is this real am I gonna
wake up and be in a van still and be
like oh my God I actually died of carbon
monoxide
yeah there was actually no pandemic
right
everyone was happy and that would make
me sad yeah man no you just I know yeah
this story is awesome man thank you do
you think that I'm autistic
I think the whole world the whole world
is on the Spectrum like everybody has
Tendencies right yeah
but
it's thinking more Asian and artistic
right Asians are all like this you're
are you honest
but that's what people think I think
that I am more uh intellectual and more
like in my own head and I'm less like
emotional and like fresh and like loud
and American no I think I like Korean
culture more yeah and the Korean way of
being and I try to incorporate that into
American culture what two things better
Korean Sushi or Japanese sushi Japanese
sushi yeah
Korean Sushi is seaweed on the inside is
better than the seaweed on the outside
um yeah I guess so uh I mean we have
kimbap which is like we got the seaweed
wrap and rice but then inside it's just
like vegetables and like meat yeah
that's not really Sushi I love I mean
it's more expensive to make Japanese
sushi so obviously it's going to be
better but kimbap uh Korean that's not
really Sushi well it's good if you're on
a road trip if you just need to like
grab something it's like [ __ ] like a
banana yeah but yeah it's a different
thing but obviously yeah I Love Sushi
more I'm not really a big fan of kimbap
Kim pop
okay yeah okay
right exactly so what do you think like
in general
um
you think men are smarter than women
what the um
we all have different experiences
we do we all have different I just think
that um
they've been a different ways of looking
at things and experiences and just need
both it's like a left hand and a right
yeah you need both energies you gotta
jerk off with both hands but like yeah
just
what happening now just
culture they're changing yeah do you
think that's good do you think it's good
that we're moving away from monogamy and
not nuclear families I don't
I think I don't know um
it's good to have both sides going up
yeah it's good to have both influences
well it takes a village to raise a child
right so maybe we should work on having
a village that isn't so like stratified
and everyone's in their own little
bubble and no one's ever interacting
with each other that's bad for kids and
it's happening now
I grew up playing street hockey outside
I grew up just like like the thing
outside yeah I grew up being outside on
Rollerblades or on either you just wear
shoes shoes
mostly shoes it's just running around
slapping each other you know just like
gets yeah and like now you hardly see
kids outside
you seem more like young
girls outside a young boy the things are
changing
yeah they're getting more you know the
things that it's becoming strange a
little bit yeah I mean our neighborhoods
are just basically highways for giant
trucks to drive through at 60 miles per
hour you can't really play there so
maybe we should create human-centric
design and make it about people instead
of automobiles and then we can have kids
playing outside right
um what do you think about public
transit
um
um I don't like it I don't know I
it is useful yeah so I like the it's and
Toronto can be scary sometimes yeah it
can be situations we're trying to just
yeah
the homeless necessary homeless and I
like and tomorrow I don't live downtown
so I have to use public transit
and situations can
arise
yeah from it have you ever tackled a man
jerking off before
have you
know
um no I've tackled people before
tackle people in the summer clothes
modern Subway yeah well I think like if
you're looking at a city and you're like
wait a minute these people all go over
here at the same time why don't we
create a [ __ ] track that can just
bring people over there and the thing
about Toronto is a subway system could
be a lot better if it wasn't for
corruption it wasn't for like
people complaining about the politicians
and stuff like that yeah Subways yeah I
mean Robert Ford Rob Ford wasn't he like
against public transit
he was
and then yeah like he was
he was a very like
he's very into saving money he's very
intellect the physical side of it yeah
and um like he changed
he changed a lot of things when he was
in there that people didn't like he took
away
a lot of
free things yeah that politicians
is there heaven
yeah he's like why are we giving this
[ __ ] away to people that paid for it
their taxes for free we should give this
to big businesses more no he was the
opposite
killed more for the people than really
yeah that's why yes I thought he was
eating all the people's food that's why
he got so fat yeah I don't know he he's
some good sound bites man
yeah he was a he was a good content
creator yeah he was con yeah
it was really before content so it was
good yeah I've been enough to eat at
home
that's the one in the lines
um yeah we know buddy
yeah no isn't he dead yeah you got
cancer some people can say
some conspiracy theories
no they're like oh the Illuminati gave
him a giant gut and forced him to eat
unhealthily for 50 years of his life
yeah just like I don't know just
yeah it was Pearl rough word
and that was
brother is a
premiere of
Ontario yeah
I'm glad you know
we have a lot of Fords here in America
they mostly drive them some don't run
yeah some of them they get stuck in the
snow right some have flat tires some of
them
have smelly exhaust
yeah did you imagine Robert Ford's farts
smell
[Laughter]
are you working out uh sometimes I
taking walks I like walking you like
walking yeah we're really working out uh
I don't work out as much I should though
but yeah I'm I'm pretty healthy yeah in
terms of skinniness yeah but I'm just
Asian that's just how we're born
everyone thinks like I'm running five
miles a day I just wake up like this and
Asians don't really eat the healthy good
we eat a lot of rice which is empty yeah
and that's why we're so skinny look but
that's also how you have a billion
people in China as you just feed
everyone rice and it's not brown rice
I've never seen
no brown rice is not an Asian thing no
it's white white people okay
yeah it's just like to fill your stomach
in right you have like a little bit of
flavor and a little bit of taste yeah
then everything else is just right a
little bit of juice
sweet rice and like non-sweet rice
yeah yeah we do different things with
rice yeah
it's like our [ __ ] you put yeah it's
like snow took a Canadian it's right
yeah I later
you can stop the rice in the Banana Leaf
that's good
um
yeah I don't think I forgot what they
call it but that's good yeah they're
just
pocket pocket rice rice
[Music]
sticky rice man surprise yeah it's good
empty calories you know yeah it's good I
love it I think that's why Asians are so
skinny it's because we eat too much rice
but yeah that's just my conspiracy
theory all right
um anything you want to say to the
people
thank you thank you thank you people
thank you humans and check out your
Nathan comment on Instagram check out
even Austin check me out check him out
all right don't don't do your prayer to
say hi don't do it in a platonic way
make it real sexual yeah come on give me
a hug yeah don't get a boner you must be
drunk do it you want yeah don't give him
a drunk hug
only cocaine and heroin hugs
you know heroin is like a warm hug yes
Embrace euphoric you want to do some
let's go all right all right thanks